regarde une posture il ya une globalité
la posture mais ce qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure c'est qu'il y avait aussi des
détails prendre conscience de son corps
de celui des autres et de l'espace dans
un mois ces franciliens font partie
intégrante d'une création
j'aime bien rencontrer les chorégraphes
et faire partie du processus de création
de l'oeuvre voilà en plus cela c'est une
situe du coup c'est super intéressant
d'explorer aussi l'endroit où j'aime
bien faire des expériences avec
l'univers d'un chorégraphe et en plus
son plein air ou dans un lieu
particulier
ils sont une quinzaine à se mêler à des
danseurs professionnels
le 6 juillet ils joueront turbulences
pensé par la chorégraphe tatiana julien
une création qui s'adapte au lieu de
représentation l'oeuvre a d'abord été
pensé pour le château de vincennes créer
un projet très immersif très
plein de liberté et de joie est quelque
chose d'assez festif avec le public où
il ya une première déambulation le
public circule librement dans tout le
bâtiment ils visitent le bâtiment mais
par la danse on a été complètement
emporté voilà emballé par cette
proposition puisque on n'est pas dans
une représentation classique avec le
public d'un côté et le spectacle de
l'autre la la danse elle est partout
elle entoure le spectateur et niveau des
sensations la commanderie c'est un lieu
fait pour des propositions inédites
original singulière la déambulation se
terminera en une fête dans la chapelle
avec un dj des performances de danseurs
les premières turbulences sont attendus
à la commanderie pour 21h